da geht mir vater denn ich habe
gesündigt
sprich mein sohn ja also der messwein
den sie da vergangene woche gesegnet
haben
ja ja also das war nicht am netz sein
den habe ich letzten sonntag mit ein
paar leuten im keller privat probiert
sag ich mal
und da haben wir wohl alle flaschen
messwein weg probiert und da habe ich im
keller dann noch ein altes tetra pak mit
der aufschrift male 2012 gefunden
ja also long story short sie haben sagt
er gesegnet und beete 1000 ave maria und
gott wird gnade haben wo das fühlt sich
gut an
also wirklich richtig gut ist also wow
also ja jetzt wo ist er ehrlich war
gibt es vielleicht was was sie mir gerne
weichen möchten bitte ich wüsste nicht
was nick nicht nicht nicht sicher gar
nichts auch nicht wo sie den kopf aber
jetzt haben wir so riecht verkackt nein
der gottesdienst fängt aber gleich auch
an ich glaube sie haben einiges zu
bieten
[Musik]
ich werfe mir in den raum
kindesmissbrauch klingelt da was bei
ihnen bei mir klingelt dann nämlich wird
es gab ja immer mal wieder fälle bis vor
einigen jahren durch eine studie das
ganze ausmaß klar wurde 3677 kinder und
jugendliche wurden opfer von sexueller
gewalt und 1670 geistliche der
katholischen kirche waren die
mutmaßlichen täter und ich dachte gras
ihr handy das herausbekommen was haben
die studienmacher dafür eine astreine
detektivarbeit geleistet um
herauszufinden wer in der kirche sexuell
übergriffig ist und wie haben sie das
geschafft
die haben eine strichliste gemacht denn
die daten die gesammelt wurden hatte die
kirche bereits nur halt als knapp 4000
einzelfälle
da mussten so füchse von der uni kommen
und sagen lass dir doch mal zusammen
zählen
untersucht wurden über 38.000
personalakten ausschließlich von den den
der kirche als geistliche gelten und da
kam raus 4 prozent wird sexueller
missbrauch vorgeworfen
klingt nach wenig 4 ist eine große zahl
wenn sie eigentlich null sein sollte
stellt euch mal vor ihr steigt im
flugzeug ein und das tut sagt herzlich
willkommen man dort unsere maschine die
mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit von 96
prozent sicher landen
heißt dass von 100 flügen stürzen vier
ab ganz genau habe sie stark nach
alkohol an bord ja ich könnte ihnen hier
einen kaffee anbieten das hat 85 prozent
alkohol ist aber gut 34 prozent ist eine
zu starke nebenwirkungen wenn die
katholische kirche ein impfstoff wäre
würde niemand ihn zu lassen
es wirkt fast so als hätte sich die
katholische kirche auf pädophile
spezialisiert wegen personalmangel
wie muss ich mir das vorstellen ist es
irgendwann mal bei einem meeting
beschlossen wurden hat er der chef in
die runde gefragt wie bekommen wir mehr
menschen dazu das amt des priesters zu
bekleiden vorschlägen wird wir könnten
das zölibat abschaffen
61 ja klar wenn wir gleich ein bordell
draus machen und das evangelische kirche
weitere vorschläge bitte ja wir könnten
frei um zu lassen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wir könnten uns auf pädophile
spezialisieren das ist es doch was
passiert wenn man kein sex abend dar
da kommt man auf den besten ideen die
ganze energie von penis und gehört die
kirche wirkt so ein bisschen wie die
neverland ranch für pädophile straftäter
wobei die neverland ranch für pädophile
straftäter ist die neverland-ranch
eselsbrücke und natürlich ist die
mehrheit aller menschen die für die
katholische kirche arbeit unschuldig
viele machen super arbeit aber wenn sich
aus der gruppe der chefs 4% schuldig
machen und das jahrzehnte braucht bis es
rauskommt muss man auch fragen wie viel
wussten davon und haben geschwiegen und
das klärt die kirche jetzt auf aber ganz
ohne stress also das tempo mit der die
kirche aufklärung betreibt wirkt so als
würden an die scheuer und jens sparender
mit einer task force zu arbeiten komisch
die kirche hat doch ein starkes
eigeninteresse an aufklärung vertrauen
ist auch ihr größtes kapital dachte ich
immer und dann habe ich gemerkt nee
kapital ist das größte kapital der
kirche eselsbrücke als es um
entschädigungszahlungen für die
betroffenen geht es erst die rede von
summen wie 200.000
3000 euro das ist nicht viel für
menschen deren komplettes leben zerstört
wurde
aber man zeigt man übernimmt
verantwortung was macht die kirche sie
feilscht
die kirche hat das leben von tausenden
menschen zerstört und sie tut so als
hätte sie beim einparken eine fremde
stoßstange angekratzt ja kann man das
vielleicht ohne polizei regeln und ich
gebe ihnen 50 euro 200 200 euro der
krise höher
du kannst froh sein dass der rhein
gefahren bin die kirche will nur noch
50.000 euro entschädigung zahlen
es gibt menschen die können seit 50
jahren nicht mehr schlafen das sind 1000
euro pro jahr und wenn du pech hast
wirst du genau die 1000 euro pro jahr
als kirchensteuer bezahlen das ist keine
entschädigung das ist ein abo aufs haus
das ist so als wenn du bei dem
achterbahn unfall ein bein verliert und
dann sagt der chef des vergnügungsparks
zu dir als entschädigungen dürfen sie
ein jahr umsonst auf die sache waren
ja und es dauert oft so lange dass viele
der opfer sterben bevor geld fließt egal
welchen fall der anguckt es ist immer
das gleiche muster
die kirche gibt immer nur das zu was ich
nicht länger verbergen lässt das ist
keine salamitaktik das ist die
prosciutto taktik extra hauchdünn
geschnitten
je größer das amt desto größer das
schweigen und die statements der
küchenchefs klingen immer wie es tut mir
sehr leid was da für ein unfassbarer
schaden angerichtet wurde vor allem für
unser image und der staat lässt dass der
kirche durchgehend es gibt ein
sonderrecht für die kirche das sind die
fälle intern aufklären dürfen bitte was
wie mafia mäßig ist das denn
wir klären das unter uns und der stark
ist wie eine mutter wenn der so einen
freund zu besuch hat alles klar ich habe
verschnitt hingestellt meldet euch
einfach wenn ihr noch was braucht der
staat würde das keiner anderen
organisation durchgehen lassen stellen
wir uns einmal vor in einer
waschmaschine firma werden
jahrzehntelange missbrauchsfälle
öffentlich und der chef sagt ja sie
haben wir sicher in der zeitung gelesen
von den schweren vorwürfen dass vier
prozent unserer führungskräfte
sexualstraftäter werden ja gar nicht nur
sagen stellt aber wir klären gerade
intern dass vier betroffenen eine nicht
zu hohe entschädigung bekommen und die
waschmaschinen weiterhin tun
dieses team shirt hier von uns völlig
verdreckten vorwürfen rein in die
maschine und zack war dann war da keine
politikerin kein politiker würde sagen
das klingt soll dieses mal hinterher
erklären
in anderen ländern werden staatliche
kommissionen eingesetzt zum beispiel in
australien da kam raus 7 prozent der
priester haben es braucht druck von
außen hilft auch den vernünftigen leuten
innerhalb der kirche währenddessen ganz
oben auf der to do liste des papstes
homophobe äußerungen muss ja auch jemand
machen neueste man darf keinen
homosexuellen segnen dieser
fahrradständer hier darf gesegnet werden
eine lesbische frau 9 warum behandelt
deutschland die kirche so schont die
anzahl der mitglieder kann es nicht sein
mit den neuen austrittswelle hat die
katholische kirche genau so viele
mitglieder wie der adac
wenn der chef des adac morgen sagen
würde schwule sollten kein auto fahren
müsste er noch am gleichen tag
zurücktreten
der einzige unterschied die kirche gibt
es schon seit tausenden von jahren wir
sind daran gewöhnt gewöhnung macht auch
die absurdeste normal beispiel osterhase
ein hase der eier von hühnern cloud sie
an malt und dann in fremden gärten
versteckt da wäre ja selbst bei
querdenkern ein punkt erreicht wo sie
sagen würden
klingt und seriös sie können ja mal ganz
ohne gewohnheit blick auf die kirche
gucken und sich überlegen in welchen
bereichen handelt die kirche eigentlich
so wie dies anderen vorschreibt und
überall wo das nächste ist das können
sie beichten ich habe schon ein paar
vorschläge gemacht gut dass beichte ich
dann soll ich dann drei ave maria beten
ich wüsste was besseres ja und wie
abgesprochen wenn der staat die
katholische kirche so behandelt wie den
adac könnte es sofort wieder ausziehen
ja ich weiss es eine scheiß situation
aber für mich darauf gibt es einen text
über die kirche die katholische kirche
hier drunter widersachers kommentare
dann schreibt doch immer eine neue leber
beim islam traut ihr euch das nicht und
irgendwann insel begabter ist da
angesagt dann direkt in der minute in
der sekunde
peinlich und niemandem fällt auf dass
ich in einer szene ganz kurzen
jogginghose trage mit vögel drauf wieder
keiner drauf wo ich mir denke so wenn
ihr euch so aufregt euch doch bitte die
anderen videos an deaktiviert die glocke
aktiviert euch doch mal so